this week on the true joining podcast
the three-time BMX world champion who
did things the world had never seen
before and his name is Stephen Murray
but after a freak accident
Stephens challenge in life would no
longer be learning tricks on his BMX but
learning how to breathe again
[Music]
you know you see a lion hunt and it and
it'll take the jugular mmm over an
animal that's why I thought like I was
like like it's old-time sons breathing
for me so in your mind you want to take
more breaths but you got to just stay on
however its breeding for you
you see someone is paralyzed and that's
what you see you don't see all other
complications and help things that come
with it the pneumonia is that you only
tract infections the sores that I mean
it's just he was a lot more than just
not being able to move physically yeah
he's a hell of a lot more
[Music]
[__] you know I mean that x-games murder
I'm Jen all right I'm gonna [__] win
that exclaims oh my I'm not just going
that antique buyer I'm gonna go and win
[Music]
you stripped of the money strip the
materials the house the cars and and
then you starts you you were working by
[Music]
just sittin up our bed just straight
sitting up as soon as that came up past
45 we got pass out
mmm and so then you had to learn to
build that up it's just very small
increments
the whole picture slots to spend slowly
and then it starts winding up wind out
faster and faster until points why I try
to control it and I can't then it's just
spinning faster and faster and then
flatline again third time everyone's
entitled to hope today on the trolling
podcast a world champion multiple with a
little three times have you're countin
BMX dirt chompin champion incredible
Stephen Murray MIT thanks for coming pop
yeah welcome right thanks
been a long time comin we've been trying
to make this happen for a while me I'm
really glad that you'd make it yeah
finally we yeah and fully turn of events
we went to the same high school I know
it's crazy that is modern it John sponge
came really nice thanks for nothing
Oh suddenly I just gotta say GG Burke
had the same experience of high school
and we use similar in high school I'm
sure we did have pretty similar
experience in that school so you're
you're Korea is one of the most famous
ones like in the BMX in in the X Games
community because you had this meteoric
rise and then this accident that sort of
changed your life forever yeah you know
what is it like to have gone from what
it seems like living through your body
completely for most of your life and all
the experiences you can have with this
bit of equipment to then having that
taken away from you and and then hover
the lid through your mind
much more than you have done in the past
yeah it's it's wild man yeah or sudden
things come to a halt you know like I
know yeah the first memory I have is is
just being are waking up on the bed and
I was like I was in a straitjacket mm-hm
and I realize like [__] I can't move
yeah and now and then and then it's the
reality starts to kick in and I know I
but - I didn't think about it too much
in the beginning because I was you know
I was in a trauma unit that was our you
know I was just trying to I had one
percent chance of surviving it
Jesus what the doctors give me 1% I know
I and yes do you think so I was in
survival mode for four weeks
can you can you take us through what
happened on the day of like was it like
any other normal competition or were you
feeling a bit off that day
no I I'd never been more dialed on my
bike I never felt better
mmm it was I you know I went through a
patch before that that uh you know I
went round the wrong Avenue I drink and
drugs and all you know I and and and
until I really hit rock bottom
and then it was I was picking the pieces
up was there a reason for that
well because I know the community like
their extreme people the people who do
what you did like right and they like
they live extreme poverty extreme so
what was there were you feeling down or
was there a reason he did it no I just
think you know always are I was a young
kid 20 years old and then you know you
weren't in are like 150 grand in two
weeks and you know you have no family
outdoor it's just all you know sometimes
you make bad decisions and then you go
down that route until sudden you like
what the [__] am i doing you know I mean
I you know I I one time I wake up my
kitchen
I'm just got like cough syrup all over
me and it spills everywhere and I was
like what am i doing you so that was
what really what made me realize you
know you would [__] okay yeah yeah so
I now spent six months just rebuild
myself and I just always am a [__] way
I thought I think like the championing
it mmm because that's what's gonna get
me to you know to start winning contests
again so every day I something I wore
the champion do Howard
you know every single or detail until
you know six months later I'm feeling
fantastic we're going to flew to
Baltimore it was the first round of a
mountain Dew Tour hmm there's five
rounds you know I so this is the first
one I really wanted to prove to myself
Yunnan to me there are you know I think
I can get back on my game and that can
be on top so why do we have to I need to
take a drink oh yeah yeah we worry about
going to that we'll get dire right what
is that so cool so you're on the way to
Baltimore yeah on my way to Baltimore
first around the mountain Dew Tour well
with uh with BMX Dutch um when you have
two runs three runs to to count so the
first one went down it went amazing
everything went perfect I'm like right
it's on one more run in the bag and I'm
I'm gonna win this yeah I went back up
on the roll in
I dropped in this there's four jumps so
every jump went amazing just like a plan
and then the last set I want to do a
double back look and you're quite famous
for this one on you we that's why mainly
pretty much him all right and I came in
and and I just slid out I banged my head
and I was concussed but you know uh-oh I
needed one more run so it was like you
know you just shake off a walleye and
head to the to star hill up the rolling
you know the people all like you know he
shouldn't take this one and I just might
push through it so when I got back up on
the
on the star he'll light man I just cross
my heart and said you know I said a
prayer and in my head and went down and
uh everything went amazing help until
the last jump and I'm going off the
slash jump when I spin and I took in
tight to do the rotation my left foot
just slipped off and it was a freak
accident I didn't know what was up what
was down left or right was complete
discombobulated in there
and I never then was like silent they're
just like waiting
now I landed straight on the parking lot
from about 25 foot and he just snapped
my neck and just I maybe stop breathing
I was knocked out and I remember waking
up on the floor and medics only my
friends are around me you know and he
looked me dead in the eyes like
screaming is a life or death situation
let me breathe for you I just think in a
fog you know so he intubated me to stuck
a tube down my throat stuff gets his
back or Ambu bag he starts pumping it
and you know it in effect it inflates
your lungs you know and I just focused
on the medic you know then you know when
I got into the ambulance with our
flatlined in the homilies you know I and
if it wasn't for the trauma center being
like five miles away like I wouldn't
made it and the way I wouldn't I want to
made it and with the you know the
amazing medical team that was around and
yeah just the circumstances had to lead
the way the war for me to be all make it
so when I got to the trauma center I
flatlined there again and I and then I
spent four weeks she's living in hell
and there was a
it was like a squirt I like nursing
station with rooms all around it and I
an on average someone was dying every 15
minutes it was a crazy place and did you
know that around you could you sort of
hear things from in and outside the room
why such stories from my family and
friends that way you know I didn't know
anything outside the room and I man yeah
I went through like alright psychosis
where you know beam up for three four
days you know this is pumping me for
drugs
mm-hmm and I yeah I thought like what
did that feel like a hospice crazy I
thought I was in uh I thought I was in
like a drug lab and they were using me
for an experiment
you know I will you just might include
tricks on us yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's strong as you've got to be in you
know in that survival moment yeah it's
crazy way the mind works and you know
the things that the body can do I you
know like and when you're in there
moments you just like flight a flight
mode yeah mm-hmm I know I yeah then I
thought I thought my I was laid in my
bed in my room is attached of bungees it
was on a slant and I'm windows behind us
I felt like I was like hanging out the
window
yeah so lots of crazy moments like that
I know I it's after four weeks I got on
can I just ask me you know where like
when your family come to see you for the
first time were you told at that point
who told you that you were paralyzed was
it the doctors yeah the doctors and then
my mom my mom like reiterated to me
explain exactly what's going how did you
digest that like what
wait two mice that I when that happened
die tubes down my nose my throat it was
you know communicating the first the
first time I to communicate they brought
a letter board out so we were just like
point each loved then you just like
blink your eye him and you know I just
follow up by books I was it so Jerry
such a low point man and we slide to to
grasp for something that was gonna give
me the strength to get through it you
know so my mom II just lost it when I
spot that out yeah I know I watched an
interview with your mom like right after
it happened and I think I could really
relate why cuz she I know a lot of women
like her from the northeast area and
yeah the fact is someone I knew and she
described her emotions watching you
there because there was a part of other
you were in a hospital bed but it hadn't
really occurred well that you weren't
gonna be able to get up and walk again
afterwards it was like alright he's just
he's bad off the accident but you know
you'll get back to where he was and it
was she said it was when you were first
in a chair and Johan dropped off the
chair and she said and I had lift his
hand back on and I realized that it was
I fell like a dead weight and she said
and only then did the penny drop that
yeah this is paralysis like this is what
I'm dealing with now
yeah and she broke down at the end a lot
bless her she was really good yeah
strongest woman in the world when my mom
is my rock for holding everything
together family together I mean dad -
meaning - alright brother
how did the family did you see their
reactions that did this off hide it from
you at the time yeah you know what
nobody fought payee or none of that it
was everyone was so positive my the nice
thing is just a just to maintain that
positive attitude and and stir you know
not let anything
you've come in your workers he's trying
to survive man you're trying to get
through this you can't you can't go down
the wrong our Happy New Year
so I spent four weeks man it's just let
it was really you know I'm clinging on
to life white thread and after four
weeks I thought are accepted into his
rehabilitation in Denver and it so I is
the number one ask for all in America
for weaning people I've been delirious
you saw why I need to be there that's
why I need to because you wanted to
breathe on your own yeah you know it's
the most horrible thing in the world
havin no I you know machine been
throughout that thankfully described
over like what does it feel like you
know when you see a lion hunt and it and
it'll take the jugular of an animal
that's why I felt like I was like it's
old time but Suns breathing for me so in
your mind you want to take more breaths
but you got to just stay on however it's
waiting for you mmm you ring yourself
you beats all not all it's all you know
custom do you yeah I got wrinkles yeah
always well we'll get on the up and up
in a minute
haha I'm feeling this fascinating
personally honestly like I've never
spoke anyone who's been through this I
mean Taylor yeah
so you're off to Denver Colorado yeah
rehabilitation called Craig so I'm on my
way from the trauma unit and I'll get
into the ambulance and that's taking me
to the airport to a Learjet so I can get
that quick or the haunting complications
and now some on the ambulance I'm on my
way to the airport you know when you
drunk on your young got wasted you lay
down and close your eyes and get spins
yeah and you're like oh no you know I
think I'm gonna throw a minute was like
that but my eyes are wide open and I'm
looking at the roof for the ambulance
and the whole picture in slots to spend
slowly and then it starts winding up
wind out faster and faster until points
why I try to control it and I can't
and it's just spinning faster and faster
and then flatline again third time Jesus
yeah H exactly yeah in an ambulance on
your way to a jet yeah yeah so why when
I woke when I came to it was like oh
sudden he was a real white light and
then it went like colors different crazy
colors and then and then the picture
just appeared you know all the medics
are over me and you know they just
brought me background and like to you
know you realized what happened
so that to bring me back to a hospital
to stabilize me and then it was back to
that trauma unit it's still like my room
open Jesus not just stay that for
another week just just look at no puzzle
yeah did they tell you what did happen
and why that why you flatline again I
mean there was just so much damage to my
to my neck
because because of their nature enjoying
I might the phrenic nerve to look to the
lunge which are the diaphragm
that's paralyzed on my right my right
diaphragm is completely paralyzed
my life one is partially so only operate
on you know 75% of a lung of a diaphragm
so I had to learn I so it was just
really sketchy you know my breathing was
super sketch all right had to learn how
I you know talk again we all read space
my words octave will I become a station
you see the to really well we thought
like when I watched the videos back the
via the rehab I was impressed for how
quickly you seem to get back talking
like yeah you see I would imagine you
broke the record today huh yeah here's
our wild man is just a crazy day one
thing that that I was struck by was just
positivity or not like I have to survive
I have to survive like in that will to
live because a lot of people when they
go through something so traumatic do you
don't have your outlook and they don't
help that mentality of a champion yeah
and in some of them actually wish it
would just end and and I know your
mother said on the video I watched she
actually was scared of that like that
you would go down did you ever have
those times where you would go right
down and just wish it would end or to be
honest maybe about two years after the
heart I had moments where it slash
across my mind yeah but I'm like no I
said but I now can find out what tell my
mom you know because you can't keep that
stuff ball in and that's less that's
where people end up going down the wrong
road because they can't get out the head
we can't talk about it so you know just
leaned chewed on
you know the wrong path she because she
was really worried about that like on
this video I watched she was saying now
that she actually said to someone at the
time do people who are paralyzed ever
commit suicide she'd asked one of the
doctors and they'd said no but because
they can't actually do that yeah it's
very difficult to do yeah but it
definitely was a concern of hers and
it's good that you thought that
connection we could offload on her own
yeah she's like your best friend as well
as your mom I mean everything man
yeah and you know I've got two kids and
they were very young at the time
Mason was like two-and-a-half scepters
mmm four and a half almost five so you
know dad had to be around for him well
there's a fire in the belly will this
all hundred-percent here yeah that's
quite a shift for them as well isn't it
knowing their dad being what one extreme
one lifestyle and then the other way
yeah you know what my my youngest son
Mason he I mean very young
yeah so he doesn't really doesn't really
know any different you know my eldest
son he all right sir he's my god he's in
115 no but he uh you know I told him how
to ride a bike and and I just took him
everywhere I did everything with him say
he remembers that to this day and but
the kids are amazing right yeah they
just you know they don't see any
different snow there was a couple of
moments on the videos where I tell me
honest with me I was ready to [__]
cry like because yeah I think was your
youngest claimed on you on the on the
chair he was giving you a hug and all of
that and you were taking him looking for
shopping for trainers or something like
that yeah and I was like I really felt
for you because uh as a man who can just
pick a kid up and take them down like
you obviously we're able to I felt bad
that that's being stripped away from you
yeah you know I mean like and but
the emotion given watching your kid just
not caring at all a big fall away like
they don't care that you had no Mario
not all the other very loving kids like
yeah yeah I mean so I'll live for it you
must have gone through your own process
those sort of because you know as
positive as you are you still have to
come to terms with a real changing
lifestyle
yeah and you know obviously say you went
through the dark moments but how how did
you go through that what was that like
to accept that you're not gonna ride a
bike anymore you're not gonna be
competing with you know BX games and
things like right yeah it's all I just
well I'm just always thinking of what
can do next I go how can I keep my mind
busy you know what could I fill my day
up with I'm just always finding things
to do mmm that's that's why I
that's what pulled me out of all the you
know a lot of slumps I was in and just
having great people around me man like
my friends have been unbelievable my
amazing yeah
but people go through things like this
you you say that there are some people
who will grab you and want to be around
you all the time but then there's other
people who can't bear the thought of
because you were an icon of the sport as
in you were like you are six foot two
big handsome lad shredded and you know
you were flying through the air you are
like some of you want idolize and then
some people can't bear the thought of
having to come and see you when you're
not that guy
children are Mia Hamas or anyone was the
many people who just deserted yeah yeah
yeah some why some of my close friends
didn't know how to deal with it mmm some
people can come in and hit it straight
on you know I know those yeah II didn't
know how to deal with see me you know
and no and there wouldn't be around her
either
so I was it I really feel
uh it was disappointing man I was
displaying but I also had some great
people around me mine so I didn't dwell
on that too much you know it just just
did what I had to do when whatever for
my kids or you know my family unless it
I guess there's a thing for some people
do find it quite hard to accept those X
is a massive shift only for you and
maybe selfish it selfishly for those
other people for them as well not having
that same sort of relationship anyway
yeah you know what there's see mine was
quite a wax that was quite or you know
it's quite exposed there was a lot of
exposure yeah on it but you know there's
there's noise of people out there that
you know don't have that and going
through this more with not as many tools
I guess is what I had to get me through
this yeah so to them people I would just
say it was hard as it is for you to to
go through this the best thing you can
do is just open up your mind and just
talk to someone near me and and just
offload which other than makes a lot
easier T for want of a better word do
you think he went through somewhat of a
grieving process of losing something oh
I definitely I mean you know I was not I
was not a BMX rider anymore yeah I'm
just thought I am well you can actually
tell us that there's a novice leave the
way you're welcomed into the community
whenever you turn up in an event
it's like Elvis haha you have the
demeanor of a BMX rider do you no no I
mean well I'll tell you what the action
sports community have been just
unbelievable man like there's a lot of
support that they give me I can't thank
my enough snow maiden do you still
follow at this book oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure
you sort of sponsor some of the latter
with the strong Brian
clothing like you you started doing what
was why did the word stand strong I mean
so much to you
well after after my accident the
following due to the phone
BMX event all right they had these rocks
Laurel Energy Drink walk slowly
they had these t-shirts made you know I
did stay strong in the front they had my
name on the back you know I know the
riders wore that following one and it
was just a message of you know you can
do this you know just no matter what
you're going through just stay strong
how did that make you feel watching them
it was really cool man it was really
humbling yeah mmm ms:i so so from there
I was like alright what am I gonna do it
can be you know they couldn't do I could
make a living off but also do it with
the purpose and the meaning you know
yeah and I and that was the the Baathist
a straw nose was the it learned it or
you know talked into a clothing line to
begin with you and now it's a bike
company too so it doesn't actually sound
that it was a very long time between you
sort of picking up sort of some of the
threads that you see now like a book and
the clothes and the bikes they're not
very long between the accident and that
actually starting so doesn't really
sound like you have much time to sit
around and think you know that's a good
day yeah because you sit around and
think then you know no me no that's
that's not good for me yeah yeah and I
mean right after accident you know I'm
you know you know I don't lie upon
totally I admit to you know I got hooked
on the painkillers and and you know
though valiums and whatever you know all
them are will stuff the doctors throw at
you and you think you know in the
beginning you know you wouldn't need
that but then after a while you're in
this vicious cycle you
I know you become relying on it yeah
even if you've recovered as much as you
can do yeah you can you don't need that
anymore you just keep on doing that of
habit because yeah your mind's poisoned
by buying the stuff and now and you
think you're entitled to happen it after
a while because he become addicted yeah
all right
and I was going through an extreme
amount of pain in the beginning and then
eventually that surprised like because I
would have assumed that you wouldn't
have been able to feel like a great deal
because of like my lack of education on
this subject to be honest with you what
what kind of pain what was it that you
were gone through well it was my pain in
my neck right start with and then one of
the one of the worst types of pain or
like after the accident was our if you
had they say that you can't feel
anything from way paralyzed right but my
spinal cord is not completely severed
right it's partially severed
so this store meshes going down from the
brain right down to the body but your
nervous system is confused as though
what the hell is going on so I receive a
lot of neuropathic pain and it's like
god it's like I imagine like a wire like
there's the nerve and the nerves inside
of it well it's like all that insulation
around it the rowboats been stripped and
it's just like firing pants like we it's
like we got a road rash when you fall
off sometimes
oh yeah yeah and imagine when it gets to
the height of the pain well that's what
it's like and it it comes in our in
waves I can't still you know ten years
later they kind of put a finger on it
sometimes is completely overwhelming
sometime it's fine yeah but I
but you know III didn't even realize I
never realize I was such a mess on
always prescriptions yeah then I retired
oh yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah and then
they are you know you see video you saw
from Nana
you'd be like God [__] you know I need
to pull myself out of this yeah you know
I yeah and then it was I you know I
didn't end up cleaning it up
no yeah I don't have that issue anymore
was that sort of completely alone or
were you because I mean part of it is
also my instant thought of an addict is
someone who's quite alone quite distant
from everyone for us but you actually
have to have someone who or not enables
you but gives you right so you've got
some new can actually monitor how many
drugs you in take yeah exactly what that
was the hard thing is when I was going
through that bowel was I you know my
caregiver lived for me full-time
hmm is he didn't want to see me in pain
but at the same time yeah he knew he
knew there was a limit he news done
something not wrong but kind of not
yeah I wasn't the beginning you don't
really you just want to make sure that I
guess looking from a carers point of
view you don't want them to be in pain
alright I thought you know meet you but
I did you over aggressive when you need
it no no no I wasn't was it itchy and
scratching where were you during this
time where you still live it because one
thing we haven't mentioned is you you
visit California office and [__] chill
chill guy that you wanted to live in
California so soon as you're 18 you
moved over to California England yeah
opportunity yeah I grew up in Newcastle
not shield didn't read there California
of courses hahahaha yeah it is yeah haha
it is quite as quite a free lifestyle to
be honest it's a lot more chill Logan
[__] that's what I was thinking oh it
seems a lot more chilled out do know
yeah I love it though every time I'd
know what it's like
feels really yummy
and how do you maybe we should start a
little bit earlier than California
because you always want to move to
California or did that become a dream
yeah oh wow
four five years old really oh yeah so
did one you when you were a kid will
just pull right back to start when you
were a kid did you just jump on a bike
and think [__] I'm in love with this I
look this is it this is what I want to
do yeah a hundred percent I started just
before my third birthday Jesus
yeah yeah my dad or I'd start BMX racing
to begin with I you know my dad have
pushed me up over the jumps have low
yellow buzz bike was stabilized
all right but yeah that was it I was
hooked and that was it just always
wanted to be on my bike always know and
quite daring oh yeah I was terrible
yeah might not put my parents do well
you know trips to the emergency room all
the time yeah broken arms but what kind
of what kind of personality would you
classy summers when you're a kid because
obviously people are gonna look anything
well obviously a daredevil but I mean
you come across as a very kind and
gentle person really yeah that's right
Roy be huh
alright I just think you know if you got
a view if you can when you get a third
chance at life like make the most out of
it and and you know just do kind things
do positive things and it's a lot of
built-up wasted energy trying to hate on
something right and so uh yes the
attitude I dropped in and you know I
always had that but
there's a lot a lot of things that you
know I mean it would just it became when
you stripped of everything you got you
realize what you got you know you
realize we stripped of the money strip
the materials the house the cars they
define their you know I wore like stuff
and and then he starts you you were work
we boy and and and some of it was
disappointing but at the same time I
didn't dwell on that I just rode with
all the positive people my there's only
have some people when they go through
something like you've been through in a
way it feels like you're getting robbed
at the time but when people the button
it still names do you think actually I
wouldn't I wouldn't ask for that to
happen there was but now looking back on
okay and a lot from that robbery yeah
you know what the good thing about it is
is uh you know I don't like blow my own
trumpet but I'd be no I have helped a
lot people hmm
I know I I wouldn't have me not to do
that if I bring get hot well if you
didn't take the path I've chosen here so
that's that's that's the great thing
about that is a lot of people they found
inspiration from what I've been through
what differently hopefully the high
thanks so I sort of back to when you've
when you almost first for getting into
biking and you got you you see the three
when you first started yeah and then you
started getting into the dirt trails and
the jumps and things like that and your
dad started pushing you around and then
when did you start to sort of just go
down on your own and become a bit more
independent when I was four Wow Jesus
yeah I know and I just I just got hooked
on it and then when I was five I became
burst champion at the five five yeah
raiga 508 in fact yes so that
competition the competitiveness inside
me
very competitive yeah yeah we've got out
of with that with everything yes by the
bike so like if someone wanted to play a
computer game with you yeah yeah yeah
definitely
so would you see someone else do
something and you think I want to do
that to our or I can do that better
I hope and say I'll do that better but
wicked yeah it seemed appealing or
dangerous yeah I'll be right there
sorry so sort of anyone doing jumps
anyone backflipping anyone sort of yeah
well there wasn't really too many people
around where I lived that was into BMX
really right so it's quite small circle
really yeah yeah yeah but you know I
would always be looking for you know the
biggest cub to jump off or bunnyhop over
someone's bike or you know just you know
lots of weird things in Newcastle like I
said this is a sport that is American
really like dominated by the Americans
and you were able to excel and go over
they improve that majority lanskin - yes
that's right okay
what what is it about you do you think
that made you a champion
what what do you have I think it is from
growing up at an early age and and
seeing not role models and seeing the
way they act and seeing their attitudes
and seeing or why are they champion what
are they doing like and pay attention to
every little detail and now I only look
to winners alright that's what I wanted
to be so so if I could take an adult or
you know certain person IOI's or things
they know you know I had some amazing
people around me I grown up just racing
BMX you know we'd uh it'd be the same
crowd but you'd be traveling you know
all over England start with and then it
became
you know all over Europe and then it all
over the world and you see this you know
thousands of amazing people or friends
yeah all right and you're traveling all
over the world doing what you love to do
so it's like not even in it the fact
that you loved doing it that was your
passion one of the things really
interesting is you became famous for it
was at the double
ba-da-ba frozen yeah how do you think of
that and then how do you make that
happen the first year in America
broke eight bones in seven months and
she's three knockouts and I was a mess
so over that winter I started riding you
know really odd and I learnt hot would
crash you know you went to America
without knowing how to transcribe what
enough is when I went to America I was a
BMX racer yeah more than you know it
wasn't really a career path in in
freestyle or in Dutch humming this is
fairly new and I though it was a dream
of mine to be out you know I got two
year contract but the first year I just
broke myself up and I had this doctor in
Ipswich and I used to go back there as
soon as I got a heart I'd go back there
and I'd walk into his office and I say
I'd broken once I had a broken
collarbone shoulder blade and wrist and
I and this guy he heals a lot of
Speedway riders but what he does is like
first you go on the hyperbaric chamber
this is what I do used actually yeah I
mean it's just good for recovery and
healing ya know you go your body's able
to carry so much more oxygen to the
joints mmm it's alright so I did that
and then I'll go into a room and he
would put like
the it's our guy I forget the name like
a electromagnetic magnet mmm
like over the break okay and what that I
do is it's emulate their healing oh and
it's like draw all the bone healing
properties from your blood to the to the
injury and then after that was done it
was you know you couldn't feel it and
then he would bring this massive laser
out and I and it was used to foster to
heal old racehorses like you know a lot
of people quite millions at the
resources well horse breaks the clay can
it just chill out on the couch can it
for you know six weeks so it's a wave
and then inside welding the bone
together knitting it together and making
it solidify so I know hey so when this
laser comes out he puts it over the
break and all that our calcium and you
know the property to the blood to heal
the bone it gets drawn to there and then
the laser like hardens it so like with
you know you know a weakened back it
just doesn't even seem real but
literally I thought I'd go in there one
time worn-out collarbone my shoulder
blade my wrist in one week clay I was
right scary part don't believe that he's
crazy
yeah so I would just do that I'm repeat
every time I get high I bounce back to
England you think that was in a way a
bad thing because it made use of not
respect what was going on to your body
and how bad it was on the body I know I
wasn't even thinking of that right maybe
a bit broken you
would have been a bit more careful
potentially or you know what I just
never I never like anything you like or
send me back it at the end of the first
year mm-hmm let me take a drink
noise we saw the medication yeah joining
both oh yeah yeah pin in the Austin it
ah Mike Mike so we're at the point where
you you've healed bones and then Brian
said did it sort of make so I'll be
careful
I was asking don't you stay on my own
sort of thing of like do you ever think
that maybe you could it be more careful
at that point or no how old were you
know happy so you would have been 18 or
19 at that point yeah I was 19 20 years
so at that point you know I can still
quite relatively fear this guy I never
broke a bone to I was nineteen nine
hundred broke eight and so much off of
that this is why it could endure like
four so that that was the first year of
me actually be paid to be a Dutch jumper
but not a racer so was our moving into a
new toy that's she pretty amazing there
isn't it but you can go through that
long on a bike that you had any serious
accidents before you went or do you
think you're quite lucky too yeah oh
yeah it's viewers 1-yard but before you
went to California yeah and but no
Berlin learner so I mean lucky in a
sense but yeah yeah how lives a lot of
concussions yeah well I mean the
concussions are quite serious from it
there's like a lot of research we've
done on them right now from people in
all sports way like when you had a lot
of concussions over the years
it sort of Ages the brain and stuff like
that in it you can send people like do
lining yeah how much they lose their
mind at the end of it so lame yeah yeah
like oh you have a chip on the button
worry about that so slow ah no no no
woman it's all good
you're a no regrets kind of dude on you
know exactly on a beside ya I was spoke
oh yeah so anyways at the end of that
horrific yer mmm
I started questioning myself if you know
if I should just go back home and go
university and no I was like you know
what [__] this [__] I'm gonna dig deep
and I'm gonna ride harder and and over
that winter ugh I mean I got really
really good I was doing no and I got
obsessed with it you know
so the first contest the yeah it was
alright it was like back then was four
runs three count and I'm up there with
you know what my idols yeah and I know
sudden you're on the same stages I'm
yeah how did I feel or what to begin
with I was you know I was never sore on
them people because all right Yoshi Oh
suddenly sharing the stage with them and
they're looking at you and I but at the
same time you can either look at them as
being just so good or what they do or
you could be like oh I can I can I can
hang with these guys yeah so I'd
practice that that event over and over
and over and over and over I leading up
to it and and I knew I could win that
contest I just knew I could do it we
accept practice so much all right
and then it came down to his four runs
three count and after the third were run
out I want it and that was the qualifier
from X Games and I the X Games all the
other big show yeah it's the pinnacle
for us boy yeah alright so I had one
more run I was like man you know I had
seen people try double flips not seeing
them that broke off hard I
I was like I think I can do this I got
one more run have you done it before no
see this is the first type you ever
tried it was fine in front of the crowd
yeah you go to do it though yeah I never
completed this trick you don't even try
that never tried it man
and I think this probably shows a
mentality moment ha ha ha yes had one
run throw waste I'm like alright so this
fall jumps and I go down and I just pull
up on the one before it and just get all
the pump and just crank and then just
hug yourself backwards no technique no
form just completely all wrong or you
know and to do that you have to touch in
a baltoro take I was all pencilled
outspoken was horrific and I came in my
nose dived to land in bent my bike in
half and knots all about I woke up when
I qualify for next game oh I thought
this story ended differently ha ha ha I
thought he then I thought that you
landed it and everyone was like oh
you're a movie moment see other ways
built that uglies they put all the talk
business in front of his face and again
sounds like another turning point where
you don't really want the competition
you don't want nothing to lose except a
bike and I guess whatever I was great
but you but you see you didn't land it
but that sounds like another sort of
turning point where you realized that
you could land it if you put your mind
to it
exactly yeah so what went out what
didn't really set in here until I drove
away from the contest and I'm just
driving they're like [__] odd I mean
X Games man again all right all that
[__] window exclaims I'm not just
going that take part I'm gonna go win a
little ha ha ha a new series and it was
sort of a diluted thought this is
something where you think I can actually
win this 110% yeah how did you why were
you so why were you so sure is this is
this inner self belief or as this you
watched
exclaims you know you can beat these
guys what is it that you're generally
from no it's just an assault belief
himself
and I knew then that I had to go away
perfect technique and I knew had to have
another kind of a trick to uh thing so
it's probably about five months until
the X Games and the thing that was I so
hard was keeping it under wraps from
everyone else and so I would go out go
ride by myself one skate box closed I
was good with a guy that owned it and no
I I'd be in that like 11:00 12:00 at
night and and I being like God the phone
pits and I know we just go over and over
and over and over and no and that's not
to perfect it
and then and then it just became like
second nature cos you know I know but
I'm gonna keep doing it Oh thousands of
run and I ha and then when I went when I
went to the X Games to Philadelphia 2001
I was like man this is why rocky years
man why he's my hero he's actually a
pretty like that he's a cool place I've
been a it seems like this amazing really
buzzing spree going to see the steps and
you see what ya did that day before
cheesesteak sandwich ran up with yeah
yeah yeah so that sort of the arena is
it's packed and this is the be a big day
you know they're the X cubes was there
was a stiff competition nothing as well
yeah oh yeah yeah it's not the best of
the best and the best Lobert yeah you
say you've been from you do all the foam
pit in quite a while
did you actually landed it before you
went to get that so there was no point
where so and you only basically land it
into a foam pit before you know what I'd
tried it
once a contest maybe a couple months
before yeah it was after the contest and
you know you were you will feed enough
each other
alright us and then you know the contest
was over but I knew I had this in my
head and I gotta nail this you know in
media so when I did it I came I came
around landed and just blew my feet off
right light doesn't count
you know right away clean you've got it
loved it
yeah so like a gymnast yeah yeah yeah
and you know the window of opening up to
land in a double flip very small you
spending so fast and it takes a lot of
power through this like like you are
muscularly Labuan in it like you're
you're literally hunter through your
whole body weight and get the technique
right and everything and land it
perfectly this is like one of the
hardest things a human being can do I
think that's probably one of the
problems of watching the X Games is by
the end of the X Games you yeah like
they make it look easy
yeah exactly that's what you have to do
yeah yeah yeah so it was i it was
qualifying I think I qualified fourth
and I and then the next day was was
practice for the finals and this is the
key thing that really want me to contest
well practicing from the finals and
there's like a big role in on one end
you start off on you know maybe about
how high is that yeah I'd say it was
probably a foot tall just deep you got
scared all the way down it well yet
scared two-thirds of the way down then
late brakes lock let's go and then so
there was three jumps one way and then
you go up onto a massive big rolling
again and you kind of regroup you know
get [__] together and then oh I so I was
on there and I machine like our TJ Lyra
and White Knight whistling calling
Astacio and these old people
you know these are winners and I could
win the contest and I was like oh yeah
I'm gonna drop in now deliberately in
front of him and I'm gonna do his double
flip in practice I've dropped in and I
just nailed it perfect
I landed it was just like [__] and right
yeah yeah just goes mobbed and yeah and
then and then the media all around and
they want to do interviews in this man I
just I got all my [__] together and I
just you know I bounced to the hotel
when you get out of that and you get
caught up in that circus yeah so that
was a practice though that wasn't
practice yeah well Americus you're
practicing you're all practicing
alongside each other you like what's
your thought when you first learn that
are you looking back at them like you
just saw no no I didn't look around just
you you've got a mission that you're on
that's the champions arrogance so it's
like I've know I can do this sort of
thing yeah I'm not even gonna look for
you're impressed by it and now you'll be
impressed by it I'm just walking off
walk off key surprised by that oh yeah
yeah yeah you're the first guy to do it
first one yeah one so that was all I was
game over for them for me it's nice to
see you back pocket yeah so I went back
and I took a cold shower back in the
hotel I laid on my bed just just think
about it
you're just think about it and just know
what and you exactly what I had to do no
I know positive visualization was that
part of it like you're memorizing
everything in your head right now I
think then at the distant it had done
all the little the little things that
you can only feel that not you can't
teach that because you've experienced it
yeah at this point yeah so what happened
the next year then well it was practice
was that like or all evening
and then no sorry practice afternoon
then the finalists will that evening all
that you've lived yeah so you know only
add like maybe three four hours but in
between so this three ones and two count
and I I go down on my first run on the
first rate that's doing jobs everything
goes perfect and then I was sudden I'm
on that rolling on the other end my
regroup no my I'm gonna I'm gonna bang
this straight out and I I dropped in and
this is setup set before the lie set and
you know I I overshot it the setup one
yeah is that so because I watched you do
this before where it's like a little
it's like a little what feels like a
little hill gives you like a lot more
gives you that extra acceleration yeah
yeah and you overshot that yeah and I
just I just did a straight dead sailor
and I'm like my it's alright I got I got
two more runs into account but you got
you got to make him count you kidding
huh
alright and then I draw it and then and
there was my second run and everything
went perfect and I'm back on that other
rolling and I'm regrouping at the top
and it was just like there's like a
dream I just dropped in nailed it it was
crazy hours are there's a surreal moment
yeah so you landed it perfectly yeah and
when you did that the crowd calm like
men ah place went nuts yeah when I won't
annoy me I went mental
alright and all the idols at that point
also watching you yeah and everyone else
from the x-games community is watching
as well yeah you you're the first mud is
to ever do this in get it yeah yeah so
as excited as I was and I still had to
do one more road you know I had no I -
oh it's because I would have assumed
that it was once you've done
perfect run then you sort of you could
drop the mic at that point but to you
know I'll go down again mm-hm
so I I do really good under pressure
I'll put the pressure on myself
mmm I know I and then yeah and then I
nailed that run and then that was it it
was just yeah how is it then it's like
saying Grady you pull away knowing that
from that fairground that the gold medal
is yours
yeah and everyone else knows that as
well yeah yeah not tossing me up on the
shoulder oh yeah I think there aren't in
my book right there are a lot of you
there's a shot that's it yeah that
there's yeah we got a close shot or get
a close shot yeah well I'll be the water
you know it's holding pass ha ha there
you go you look you look remarkably like
a usual check pull yeah he's quite
famous he's a better looking and
slightly lesser Bert so after that we're
done which you look like this guy was
named Jay Paul okay well I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get a fork yeah there's some
people watching we won't offer foxes the
same time there so you just you just got
to watch his content it's just it really
is just so I say to you guys who sit
around in a room and was so whilst
you're whilst you're celebrating because
BMA I think what people don't or maybe
do understand about BMX and
skateboarding and that sort of that
lifestyle is actually it's different to
say football or soccer or that sort of
competition you guys are actually quite
close and there's friendships within
those groups oh yeah let me see let me
see
you know how like my son haha yeah it's
uncanny
he just dresses like a BMX guy he was
probably I don't know if you can
actually do it although I don't think
addresses that he dresses like a what we
call in England is he also see the kid
in college with a backpack on the
skateboard at can't skateboard yeah yeah
only one of them so you're the gold
medalist at disappoint weight 99 is
friendship I wonder I want to get this
one bit out because I was watching the
Signum yourself oh sorry
you watch your video interview right
after this point where you said yeah kid
from Newcastle riding a BMX and now all
of a sudden I'm making 15 grand a month
I've got a Jacuzzi outside of the house
like yeah you became an absolute living
legend at this point you're loving life
no doubt the girls are coming over I
wish I could have been been there to
sell about yeah haha what was it like
when you became the month
alright well right after I had one you
know I hide into the night and next day
was was are there was amazing but two
weeks later had or had the competition
called the gravity games yeah it was the
same as X Games at that at that time
just as prestigious yeah I I was like I
need and I know it here people were
saying fluke and you know that was a
fluke here am i right he [__] all
right I'm gonna go away and I'm gonna
learn something else has never been done
before and now I know went away in her
in that short time of two weeks I'd be
there like midnight to like 2:00 in the
morning
no I by myself you know with a friend
there you know I and I learnt 360 turn
down back look since three tricks in one
you know she do the flip and the 360 and
you kind of wrap yourself up in your
bike and alright and I remember I live
with all the time I live with my friend
I coyness tally of all right and I came
home late and I showed my old camcorder
with the you know the high eight tapes
and I was like look I might blow wash
learn on my own I don't want to go and
do this grabby
and he thought I was out of my mind
ahead half so and I left that morning
8:00 in the morning and I and I went to
where was it
Rhode Island and uh yeah it was crazy in
that and I landed that the force I was
you know there's the first time I tried
it on a jump yeah I know I know I did
that now landed so go for it
it was just and it happened all over
again
you know now wouldn't that concise to it
was up when the naysayers were shut the
[__] up
well it truly yeah yeah the silence of
mirth solidified er yeah but the
craziest time about that was you know I
I was party you know I was raging that
night and uh I met something you know I
when you part you end up find yourself
with like a random dudes that you think
a super cool and then all of a sudden
there was this kid there was this kid
from Boston it I got to meet I know I
need and he was easier part yeah no more
though you know you know he was
providing the fuel for the boy and I
know I know I got it was being like what
three four in the morning and now I was
like right I'm gonna go I'm gonna try
back with his kid to Boston and no and
I'm gonna fly from Boston to LA and will
you be partying and all of a sudden we
are he kicks a nice I don't want to ever
come down I got cold feet and I took my
original fight but that thought that
flight from Boston to LA was one that
went into 20 hours [__] yeah
it's crazy in it
[__] me with yeah I'll tell you what
this say shouldn't do drugs hahahahaha
Jesus yeah yeah yeah it's crazy man
I mean literally I just I don't you just
pack my [__] and bailed out and then
when when I arrived in LA he got on the
flip this other guy no no he drove back
to Boston yes jobs gonna continue the
party line all the way you know I am I'm
part of a minbari Maria and I yeah yeah
that's quite nice it's a kind of close
shave
yeah oh wait yeah yeah so when I got to
LA maybe like I might be like a half a
day I am at one point there was no more
yeah yeah and then I hear all the news
just how does the phone just under just
unjust you got a chilling as well
because you know you just dodged
something you know a big bullet for sure
yeah yeah but really but also kind of a
that could have been me sort of thing
which takes a lot closer yeah it was
another thing was much as my and my best
friend yeah calling nostalgia yeah a
little professional BMX on I right
before that you got this tattoo on his
arm and it was over I was the Statue of
Liberty holding a bomb and and and and
it's going up in flames
it's just weird man it's just you know
eerie you realize how much it yeah how
much she's changed since then no one
would tattoo that on anyone
yeah yeah yeah no way now ya know what a
drink
did you keep yeah yeah I wasn't
expecting you see that
ha ha ha shocking story for Corey
let's stop in your tracks all but yeah
and not expecting that she knows like I
think talk about what uh what is that
cuz in every walk of life this like the
groupies Allah and I'm pretty sure the
x-games had some good groupies was the
no women around not allowing without
that women we what was that like as you
were hunts of busted on the offer
hahaha but the tire I mean I was like
was quite shy around no yeah it was all
it was with all it all came really fast
yeah we all I had a really cool
girlfriend at the time the her she kept
me very grounded yeah it wasn't you know
I didn't want to do the doting on her
cuz she was she she was with me before
so Alicia you would not take care of
that sauce yes he was also from North
Shields
now she from La Mirada California okay I
know is there a couple of years that
went by and then you know I was lying on
you know hard to let it go temptations
were everywhere yeah yeah and did you
find is you struggle with that them all
right I just I mean for the next like
three years after that four years I
would win with more contests and I'll
get a lot of like seconds thirds but
sometimes I would be going to contest
I'll be up all night you know
before competition yeah yeah and and I
can get away with it and still pull off
you know top three and now and then
eventually it your results
yeah you know the money side of things
how did you handle that because like you
are really young lat
yeah to be on 150 grand a year or
whatever you were getting yeah well I am
yeah how did you handle that because you
don't seem driven by money I've been a
poor obviously it's unnecessary you
think yeah yeah I mean I just that to me
money just enabled me to have fun and do
things you know and whether you know I
had or you know a lot of friends around
me well I thought they were my friends
yeah I mean a lot of Klingons yeah yeah
you know like yes man you read no one to
tell me no because of the open yeah
alright and you lived in an imagined a
fancy place in some yeah beautiful house
at Corona okay I die I put my I put a
lot of money into this car is it was a
Chevy Tahoe I was like yeah okay SUV nad
you know then the airbags you bounce it
up and down and the TVs and the sound
and you know oh like I know I rims oh
yeah yeah you were not like a tipping a
lot from shields like they did any emits
from home save the kind of life you were
live in a bubble they're like oh did you
sort of lose track of them after you
went big no no no no we always go back
home New Castle yeah yeah just thought
it's not very the same yeah all right
but yeah you don't realize you don't
realize that you've got all on yes man
around you know all the Klingons me and
until you know until you shits going
downhill
yeah then you saw you drop off so you
don't want to believe that I don't think
anyone wants to believe that someone's a
friend for any other reason and chains
given reasons yeah especially when
you're in the fire you you're in the
moment and you just you're there and
this is gradually happening with funny
your eyes we can't see it will you a bit
naive do you think you're a bit
like coz yeah yeah absolutely yeah I
mean I got I got taken advantage of big
time hmm why are what a lot of different
people
mmm can you remember any ways in
particular where people would take the
piss one in particular yeah very well
he's at the time I was partying like
crazy me and no I I was at my
girlfriend's house at the time and she
heard she heard I lent money out this
guy and he walked in like a ha you deal
with high-end cars like you know
Ferraris and all that time slept and he
will use her money to get cars so on and
then you know give her the the whatever
percentage profit and it and it was
solid she made a lot of money to this
guy you know and at the time would have
been partying for three four days and I
was awake that long all right
and and I wanted to sell I had a big
lifted truck too
but I wanted to get rid of him bourbon
to get in a car you know all right so
when the guy came I just want I just
wanted to sign whatever it was the
contract sell cars you know I can barely
even see the freakin paper well what I
was written on it I was seen like five
different papers why do I sign yeah you
know I saw saying that and I left the
registration at the pink slip in my
glove box and one of the causes totally
paid off the other one I had a small
room with anyway so this guy took my
cars and he told me that he'd sold them
after about three weeks and I and I went
to meet him over the next six months I
went to meet him nine different times I
travel from Corona to Newport Beach but
now I don't know and I and he would just
won't show up
no no and then also numb just like yes
all right that so that everything start
to focus on trying to find this guy you
know everything else to go back teacher
- Abbot yeah no I so I said well I mean
it got to a point to where I got private
investigator to find out how many shops
like X detectives spy equipment this
doesn't [__] no interest in the shop
put my perfectly you know my heart my my
I wouldn't be here
I've never be in these shops and no I so
the guy found out what happened to my
car where it was and so that the car
salesman he got my car and and within
two days it got transferred three times
so he sold it and I sold it for fifty
four grand and he went and sold it cash
twenty seven grand
so the called car dealership then the
car dealership transported it to another
car dealership it was a ring of people
that were in on this [__] yeah I know
and then it got transfer weeks later got
sold Phoenix Arizona at some guy though
some white right so where's this guy lip
what's the route from the airport to his
house what's the route from his house
was walk now knew everything about this
guy and I would you know yeah what am i
doing you know I'm just on a goose chase
yeah and I so one morning me my dad
would fly out to Phoenix super early at
5 o'clock
all right I would get to this
we drive to this guy's house he lives in
a mass of my chain it's massive
alright you know waiting outside I looks
like please just roll out of my car
please so you know the cars door opens
up and I just see my baby roll our
though I hear the air bags us you know
just like did I put a lot walk into this
and I went to get out Lata I mean it's
just everything boiled over I not wanted
to you know get my car yeah at all cost
and now dad's like son he's like be
patient he's like just chill so we
followed the guy to his walk you know I
he worked at a real estate company she
got out the car I still had that the
bleep Oh to open up so I hit the lawn
and it opened it up so I get in there
get in my car not just the smell just
everything about it was like I know I so
I drove to the GM dealership I know and
I went to get a key cook for my god
and when I gave the you know the short
storm that the alarm and nothing on my
registration and well that's thought he
went away and and he came back but four
minutes later I think like like you
registrations two days I was quiet can't
get you a king ah unbelievable
so I go back to the I tell the guys what
place and I go into his workplace nice
they know he's the boss and nice and I
just knocked on his door and I might
know Mike my I need 30 minutes your time
might it's about your car and
sat down with him and and and he was
just the innocent guy on the end of you
know a crooked ass ring and I you know
went through everything with him and I
went to a little story on with all the
paperwork and I was like I'm is not my
signature on my it's not you know in the
end there's no there's nothing I could
do yeah nothing I can do I spent a lot
of time wasted time wasting any energy
and then when I got back to California I
was like Joe I've gotta let go
yeah look I just let that [__] go well
sometimes you gotta let go you know an
obsessive person as well yeah that's
like that is part of your success is
this constantly being able to drive your
mind at the MiG you achieve whatever you
say it made - yeah and this one you had
just admit defeat yeah yeah hey hey
exactly so you gotta let it go you got a
and then you use that as motivation to
just do bad on it any more money by yeah
yeah how long did this career BMX did
you meet your future wife i I was 24 24
so this was like yeah Oh years after you
won your first world yeah yeah and how
many do you want to bet intervening time
do you want overreacts games by that
point 3x gaming and grabbing games yeah
I know
yeah no no and then you know I bought
list my massive house you know and they
built you know my during the odd jumps
all around it yeah full pipes made out
would just just chill you dream of I
need you to make it become reality and I
know yeah I was living the dream for
sure that's actually what I wrote down
when I when I was researching your life
and start living the dream you were you
yeah like a young largest doing what he
loved and partied and having a great
time oh yeah
money yeah yeah so what was the
relationship like with her then because
you seem that cool oh well you know it
was I thought it was great at the time
but you know we would put we were pie
together you know what you think that
was terrible wonder there was not a good
like you know relationship for sure oh I
know and you know she beasts are taking
these prescription tabloids and I didn't
think anything over I don't know how
about a little you met just part you
don't know yeah yeah it was all out at
the PI I'm actually taking these
painkillers and tell me you know the
days they just helped me get through my
day you know take a couple I'm see all
they are try it out and I didn't think
of a big thing above it and then all of
a sudden I'm taking these things every
day you know and and and it just got
crazy you know you're getting them from
shady doctors from people or what were
the tablets called Norco is there like
hydrocodone tell us and I will feel in
the deer from all right just like
content you know you use content and are
energized and then you know but got the
point of wide you know be taking other
tablets and see what I like and you know
just experimenting in an hour and then
it got to that point to I I woke up on
my kitchen floor
you know and my parent my parent my mom
my grand I was coming at California and
got it got that bad at the time there i
I didn't pick them up sent a limo to
pick them up okay wrong move yeah yeah
you know I
you know know the time so you know I was
trying to pull myself together and they
came in I just like laid on my on my
floor watching TV just you know they
could talk to us right away yeah and I
try to shake it off I is not a big deal
and yeah it was a big deal and it was
your granddad someone you sort of
respect that I look a hundred percent
yeah so you was amazing guy yeah so I it
was just very shameful you know I know I
and I knew who I was the core and it was
try it was time to hop on that horse
again yeah stop we've always hid behind
I see you you just been sort of doing
the drugs you hadn't raven practicing
much in that time haven't really been
doing no you know what it got to a point
to where I'd be looking at my bike I
feel like no interest don't even want to
ride it yeah I just wanted like a normal
life yeah like I just wanted our
I I just wanted to have a normal job I
didn't want to do that I knew it was not
because you'd second yourself because
you put thousands of hours into this or
is it yeah well you know what I think
it's a combination both because you know
I had achieved so much and I'd been
doing it since you know I came out my
nappies you know I got burnt out at the
same time yeah it was combination being
burnt out you know all the pie in and
the consumption of you know drugs and
stuff
you know and and and then and then when
I pick myself back up I remember I
remembered what my bread and butter was
and why I really love to do and and you
know I found a new love for riding BMX
again and it started you know in it the
first couple of weeks which harder it
really was hard did you think they
step well yeah yeah absolutely
and felt like [__] riding my bike again
I've it was but I just kept pushing
through was the famous just not there no
no no no you know I've been lifting
weight you know what was quite big I
plan I got 220 pounds like 16 stone
which is also known yeah on a BMX Tara
wall man which in your in your pics you
must have been about three store later
than that
miss Milan 180 707 pounds yes sir yeah
so you'd be naturally like 13 stone guy
and then you've caught up there yeah and
I'd see video myself right in it's like
oh man that's not happening
yeah but then you know I had to also
shake all the way off and that took a
lot time surely BMX helps it's quite
good cardio that helps yeah absolutely I
know you out there riding the night you
know mighty degrees down to reach wallow
you sweat it off the big thing is is you
know I'm just pounding so much war and
now so clean my system up pretty quick
and I and then after about two or three
weeks you start to feel coming again
you thought that be in the moment when
you're on your bike
where other than just being on your bike
you know because for me I mean I've
never achieved anything like what you do
back problem I can relate it to
weightlifting because there's like those
days are going to the gym and I feel
like [__] and I feel weakest piss and
then there's other days where I feel
like I could just grip the bar and do
whatever the [__] I won do it and I'm
just untouchable
and it was a similar sort of state of
mind that you're in like I'm I'm on now
this is it yeah yeah you're the
confidence that coming in you know I
yeah because I wasn't when when you
can't make the bike do what you want to
do that's not cool feeling for me like I
like to be in in the morn we're in
control
feeling it like feeling the bike you
know well it not just being on it but
being a part of it being one everything
at one and I know I yeah and I just
thought I didn't get better and better
and better
nowhere how much of what you were that
you know you look at some champions
whether it be football box and wherever
there's some guys who are like naturally
just born to do it and then there's some
guys who aren't genetically gifted but
they work hard and they make that up and
overcome it what percentage would you
say was natural in hard work hard work
all the way yeah yeah well I wasn't you
know you've got these gifted people like
you know John Jones and fighting you
know in BMX I died Dylan clay and I
extreme amount talent these people I
have it's it's quite often that you find
in sport that the most talented people
the most wasteful and it's very rare
that you get extreme talent and hard
work combining together the ones that
they don't appreciate it then you've
produced like a Floyd Mayweather that's
that mmm-hmm all right bro with me I
don't think I was naturally talented it
just rode my ass off and that's fun
doing it you know in terms of getting
married what was it because you were
very very young to get married when you
25 yeah that's pretty much that's pretty
young when you know what was the reason
for that was there that well that was
all right what I wanted welcome grown up
having your parents are divorced and all
the crap that comes along the line with
that I wanted I wanted to have the
perfect
what kind of crime along with that and
like I just you know just that I was
proud to split up and then there's you
know it's arguments between you and I
you know you hearing you're dying is
alright quite difficult
well the good thing about in my
situation was I had my bike yeah and all
of that all of that loss was poor I just
put it well into my bike you know I
would just you know I just ride and ride
ride did you like the hoses did you go
from pair of the parallel and I live on
my mom I'll go down visit my dad too all
right but you always have my bike and
it's a foreign sport into 18 I lived in
one my right just my mom and I but I
knew I wanted to be here that was in the
sunshine ride my bike in California so
the reason you got married
what part from the fact they had met a
girl who you obviously really liked but
in the back of your head is I don't want
to do what my parents say I want to be
with someone who is that forever
yeah and that was the honest intentions
yeah yeah and despite don't just party
with her you thought that was that was
the right route to go right yeah yeah I
just actually I wanted that our norm so
here unless yeah and did she offer house
cause I don't jump all around you know
kids
he's now and everything that was
everything for me I don't know I don't
know okay the time you thought that that
was your plan together yeah yeah and you
had kids not long after that yeah yeah
yeah cuz they they well I think they
were I watched a video of them and yeah
that's true like it was six months and
yeah I'm out pretty quickly yeah yeah so
you've got your now this young
successful man got a couple of kids like
how do you help you what was it like
when you first had the boys two ladies
have got me
when I met my Melissa she she had a son
Artie he was a year when I [__] my
hand wasn't and then I and then I
started to you know be around him more
not more and then when he was two I just
moved them both in with me and then I
had Mason and Mary's and then Mason came
along and no yeah I was
you good would you say you were a good
that I think so yeah sort of came
naturally to you yeah yeah I mean you
know we're all well human or makes
mistakes were no one's yeah you know but
you felt quite like a bit too paternal
father yes sir oh yeah a hundred percent
and then [__] the bed when they become
dads but like judging by the video I've
seen you just straight in their
naturally tea yeah and they were thrown
are sort of drugs at that point you
cleaned up or which point when you had
your kid after other kids
yeah yeah you were yes we you both yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah - the midnight not
not straightaway
it's thought I still took the line and
that was the thing it's the guilt of
partying yeah and having to beautiful
look human beings that you're
responsible for it's like the guilt was
tremendous money
alright do you look at them the day
after and things think oh yeah yeah out
feel terrible yeah I feel terrible you
know all right
did they make you grow up generally yeah
absolutely yeah and then you know what
what happened was are you know the
sponsors thought you dry up you know sir
all of a sudden you know you you barely
know you got one or two sponsors where
you had ten before I thought because you
weren't achieve it on the exact right
yeah yeah I think well I think
you know it got out there a little bit
you know I was a little a little bit
Wilder I know I adventurous haha but
your responsibility as a man at that
plate this summer right for this family
and then you're like I'm [__] letting
them down
right so that's what I wanted to get a
normal job
yeah yeah yeah what what kind of normal
job did you want I don't mind really
doing anything right I do anything just
like whatever would support
why I just cuz I I'd done this all my
life at this point and I couldn't see
how that you know when you lose your
support and sponsors it's like you go in
till I almost are not desperation well
but like I you know I started growing a
lot weed in my house tip cell or to
smoke to make money yeah right yeah yeah
to provide for my family I know you know
in California it's it's legal now but it
was it wasn't then but it was a slap on
the wrist
you know I know and I'd crazy operation
on my house [__] hell yeah yeah well
much money would you say you will make
enough for that like ah I pray say off
my first one 14 grand of my first one of
your first batch first batch but then as
soon as I'd done my first batch you see
there would be okay you come to Mexicans
alright we've had a few people talk
about Mexicans may I see my son so he
come to Mexican yeah so they'd be the
they're be the klingons yeah and
you know that they would they would look
at us and see how they kind of latch on
and mooch on onto a lifestyle right you
know
so then what they would do is cold one
would have it I you know they've been
drug dealers all right and they would it
would get houses like maybe a mild
couple miles from mine and then they
would have a fake yard to put up like
dirt jumps around the house copy what
setup but I have what try to and they
can do a good job of it but to the
normal person and I guess you know
that's it that's that cowboy you know
that's can I just say that's really
unusual behavior isn't it that's I've
never thought like you I know I don't
think I'm gonna go and buy a set of
weights to impress Bryan you've not
noticed people copy of us notice that
most people copying but I what what I do
find unusually is building jumps in your
own back garden especially as they I'm
assuming they don't have bikes no yeah
mate I just thought some jumps in my
back garden
why well it was I just loved the
taillights it'd be vicious
Amelia didn't either try there's a cover
and what they say they think what they
so call you me liked wanna come run my
house and sort of do some uh yeah they
would know her what a there is in it for
the money man
that was their way of living the
lifestyle you know and with a what
people considers for stereotypical
Mexican excellence yeah what was that
one Mexican drug lord
but the door we Leah it's not the accent
they have um but was so were they so
stereotypical what people would imagine
when they think of it I think they're
slightly cooler than that yeah right
uh well Charles not really cool like
hahaha you don't say no just ask you
were obviously used to a very large
amount of money coming in from the
sponsors and in you'd become accustomed
that I've gained a lifestyle so when you
said I like a normal job I did think of
yourself going from 150 grand a year
whatever you ended up on a top level to
a normal salary when I see a starting
wage yeah it would have been very hard
so was that part of it why you started
growing the wheat because it's gonna
bring a lot of money in yeah yeah yeah
what happened so I have to after my
first batch haha first bunch
I heard the what you know an
acquaintance I won't call my friend who
had the whole setup the big cover his
house got busted and I was like alright
I'm [__] next because look I'm a
duplicate he took what well I've got
going on so I just ripped everything
down well that was a I was ripped
everything down and I know that was the
end of Mario you know Breaking Bad style
yeah we so you had all the lights are
like and that you know so I went through
all these wrong avenues that I realized
in the end you know that I was I was
making stupid decisions you know I and
you know that was when I started to
throw all back into my bike again right
it always comes back with a but yeah for
the third time yeah yeah you're so sad
you're religious oh you sort of you say
a prayer would you do you say actually I
really miss always yeah yeah I believe
in God yeah yeah sure and so
it sounds a lot like you sort of strayed
from the path of what most you know sort
of kids were brought up religious yeah
that typical yeah I'm not that's not me
I just I said as for me I feel like that
everyone has their if you believe in
something then you have your own
relationship with what you believe in
it's not someone else's relationship or
how you should be to believe in the same
thing now it's a personal relationship
man all right you know I'm not really
the too outspoken about it or it's just
it's why I believe in this yeah yeah
yeah join us talk to her now especially
you know you're the one getting
questioned a lot of the time of lot of
stuff yeah with this these bright lights
it feels a lot more like a police
interrogation yeah which is i haha sort
of polo out of it yeah crush King
Gomorrah
[Music]
Oh Charlie do you ever watch our narcos
yeah off fiddle but I haven't seen the
incredible it's good yeah I am oh yeah
yeah is older in religious Mexican
laughs what happened in some perhaps up
toy oh yeah he's dead he's dead now
isn't he yeah well you [__] Jew
honestly no you know that he died but I
don't have a clue do what yeah I lost it
yet no it's not about it's not about his
dealer when I stay where your gallery
Ari
all right so that was the thing as I
started to see I started to see what was
going on with every other drug dealer
knew and you were there and that's you
know get killed or you can end up in
jail and that's to place or I don't want
to be yeah send her back to the bike
yeah bike to bike back to the basic
right you know but that's really not
good up so I'm surprised you ever
steered away from it in a way yeah me
because this you can't I know you you
said you were more hard work but at that
point that was what you were good at
yeah what was the aim of going back to
the bike because if you've liked if all
your sponsors have dried up was your aim
to get back in with those guys and start
to I well the thing is is if you when I
went back back into work full swing or
all them all that followed was you know
like you just gon ride and ride your
best and love what you're doing and just
you have the passion and the drive
everything else comes behind it right so
that will all come and yeah I wasn't
worried about that you knew that route
back in yes success breeds all of that
as well doesn't it yeah absolutely yeah
so that was this the final are we now
one on the sort of run up to
till you crush that your hood yeah now
this is the this is where you sort of
double down you say right I'm gonna make
a good call this and how that was that
time how long was what come on what's
the time from when you decided to start
a go to when you started competing again
and six months okay five months
so from sorry from quitting the dealing
to the crush was was that five six
months yeah
all right it's long we had a long time
at all and now I know and looking back
on it do you
okay I guess I'm wondering do you put
any of the crush down to maybe taken
time off or is there any explanation
that you've got for it in your head that
might have been the journey that weevil
Sutton listen to here thought you can
pinpoint anything or was it just a freak
accident
Oh absolute freak accident yeah yeah
complete freaking on my foot just
slipped off mm-hmm when you rotate in
that fast it's so much this many genes
you know you know for the roses I see
you Alejo but you said you're feeling
the best yeah I never felt better on my
bike we're just incredible really yeah
yeah yeah that must be a pretty
empowering feeling yeah just know like
you know like if anyone's listening if
everyone is at a point in the life
whether the down of the dumps and their
point hours you just you know you just
got no Drive in anything you know you
can't pick yourself back up again in it
you know I can get you so back on top I
guess that's what I take a lot from your
story me as you had a lot of times where
you could have just given up and you'd
never have even after the accident you
still yeah find new things you're always
you're always gone
yeah do you think you do you think your
mentality is quite a unique one because
it doesn't sound like one that you kind
of come across every day I don't know I
don't know how to answer that question I
mean do you do you consider yourself to
be the same as everyone else is like do
you just think I think so I know that
you all know I make a lot of people and
I me a lot of successful people
and I don't know how many people would
have the state of mind you've got like
like recently we had a tea hall on who
was like world Strongest Man and he he
reminds me of you were in a way because
he's the type to he wants to do things
I've never been done before right
and that's very much in post crushed
beforehand the tricks you wanted to do
would never done before you know what I
mean but that's why it's all about yeah
if you take someone sort of super power
away from them in an instance I don't
know I don't know how many people would
be able to just change ya into something
completely different and find something
totally different yeah you know what as
crazy as they are after the third day of
being in that trauma unit yeah oh my
eyes and I there's these two guys next
me sat down next to me one like me age
like mad scientist looking guy and the
other guy probably about 15 these are
the doctors other what these the thing
was absolutely bizarre is the guy that
looked like the mad scientist was
Christopher Reeves doctor Wow
and all right and he walked with
Christopher for eight years and and the
guy next door him was the world's first
fully recovered cordial politic so that
was just like and in the comparing MRIs
and I it's like strikingly similar right
and I so it was just and these guys were
just like I mean it's it's right there
in front of me it's possible you know or
so that was just great motivation man I
mean very lucky that you know had Sam I
don't it yeah yeah yeah it's crazy right
you have you
1% chance yeah you made it yeah I was
able to be in that 1% sometimes it feels
or sometimes it feels like you know yeah
this isn't it you see where this injury
comes on you see someone is paralyzed
and that's all you see you don't see all
the other complications and health
things that come with it the pneumonia
is that you need tract infections the
sores that I mean it's just there's a
lot more than just not being able to
move physically yeah he's a hell of a
lot more yeah and I know I even though I
can't really feel although my shoulders
I became very much more aware of my body
and that doesn't really make too much
sense it with because I can't feel like
but I'm very aware of where my limbs are
would have positioned I making sure that
I'm not gonna get any stay away from all
these are health complications
I mean Christopher Reeve he died of a
bed sofa sounds crazy during this yeah
but so do you think you've become a more
conscious person yeah because I that's
what I'm picking off from you like yeah
yeah yeah because the the man who's made
all of these silly decisions in the past
I don't think you'd make any of him
though no no I mean no no I got do orbit
and you know just me get out for my kids
yeah you know God
oh yeah
as crazy as a disparaging said the man
the man who recovered who was sitting
next to you you said they're comparing
the MRIs right how long and what process
did he go through to recover and sort of
how similar is your situation days his
whole life like 30 years 35 years and
that's what it gives you an element of
hope that yeah there's a recovery
process
this thing is everyone's entitled to
hope yeah you know that's the number
that's the one thing you've got and when
you in you know in the trauma units and
flatiron Beauvoir is the hope you've
always got the hope and the doctors will
come in I when I first got heart they
came in see my family and they'll like
you son's gonna be not gonna be all set
up again he's gonna be breeding on a
respirator his whole life all right it's
just like Chris don't worry mm-hm I mean
like broke my family down but I was like
no that's not the way I'm gonna be you
know the doctors can't dictate the way
it's gonna be you know there's there's
always miracles that happen there's not
always miracles but there are miracles
that happen that doctors can't even they
can't explain it you know and and dad to
me I just that god-given miracles that
just happens on his time and not yours
so yeah I've engaged myself from
rehabilitation since my accident like
non-stop I know
and at the beginning I thought it'd be
like going into a gym and lift some
weights right you know going my teeth
and you know just make it happen
uh slow man
yes snails flow all right can you give
us an idea of what it was like on day
one and what it's like for you now
by comparison well first bit of
rehabilitation I did was was weaning off
the vent oil like coming off it learn
some when they first brought me off at
our last 20 seconds I was thinking that
would scare the [__] home there now
you're back on the vent so it's like and
then you get to light what were you
doing when they first took the vote lay
off you what how did you realize it's
trying to breathe her yeah trying to
breed and then they you know the
monitoring you very closely and I and
then we'll see when you getting into
trouble gonna put you back on and then I
built up to 50 seconds and then it was a
minute and then two minutes and then
four minutes and you know it gonna start
to get more and more up at the same time
you again yeah a little something then
foam right smack back down you know back
to the death grip yeah all right
and then eventually I got up to 18 hours
off and my and then my carbon dioxide
level fill up so why that I went all the
way back down to two ah man he's just
gonna [__] let her and then just
falling right oh yeah you're smacking
back down not here I know so that was
the first bit of you know so that was
then when I realized oh it's gonna be a
[__] long haul
I was a you-know-what like all of the
trainer needed for the BMX and you know
it's a totally different song objective
but you've got to take on yeah was that
training yourself to do one thing you
used to trade on yourself training so in
a way you have it's soft your mind is
kind of built for this [__] fall off
your bike get back on I think everything
my life leading up to this was was
designed for getting through what
getting through yeah yeah alright so and
then then the next thing was like just
sitting up all bad just straight sitting
up as soon as I came up past 45 you pass
out hmm
and so then you had to learn to build
that up it's just very small increments
and you know my dad explained it to me
in the beginning and I didn't really
understand what was talking up I get it
now yeah he's like a son he said you you
like a flower and he's like you get the
seed and you plant it doesn't grow very
quickly take some time but if you wore
it you can give it are you know you give
it all the things it needs to grow
slowly but surely you like it oh grown
he's like there's light at the end of it
all take some strength from a diaper see
that there was some who's going through
that what's your relationship with him
like no ah it's good yeah it's good but
now I'm living watch you know see my mom
every day
alright see my dad every couple weeks
that's what you know so that was what it
was like then uh it has all the work
you've put in really made a massive
difference to your life would you say
like because I don't know like you
sitting in front of us now did other
ever times you need people back when
evently are these days yeah
so that's it you know what one time one
time because like one when I go to sleep
at night oh when I would go sleep at
night you know you breathe in shallows
down and done it there's so your oxygen
saturation goes down same time as that
go down you've got you calm dark side
levels build up because you can't well I
couldn't I expel the common oxide and
breathe out
all right one morning I woke up and I no
no no says there are and you know we're
doing law exercises and and she said
that I wasn't making much sense and I
and I got out of that day and I was in
the chair and I have like a phone stand
the phone sits in front of me and I use
like a little mouse stylus to operate
the phone and the carbon dioxide
poisoned my whole body and brain so much
it I couldn't I was trying to call my
dad when I was I was trying so hard and
I just couldn't figure out how to do it
and then the next thing I woke up on a
ventilator I'm [__] I got the
deathcore begin and shits down my throat
and I can't talk I can't know what that
was like
Jesus help you know it's bad alright and
then I spent 18 hours on that because I
also got pneumonia at the time you're
really bad and then I spent two weeks or
two weeks fighting through that yeah so
I made it again huh and now you're
fighting me on this
yeah I gotta be in your yeah
so back to the guy that was sat next to
me was the scientist guy
all right his name's Patrick were
Matthew oh isn't it an amazing guy are
the things that he is conquered the the
triathlons and they're just the feats
that he's taken on like it's just this
is made of my much stronger much or more
rounded guy and I and I tried to be like
that guy hmm
well you've you've achieved something in
this book as well yeah you've written
your whole life story so that other
people can redevelop your journey
yeah it's called staying strong I think
there was an easy title yeah yeah you
said that you wrote this over six months
five hours every day yeah five hours
Monday to Friday
yeah just dictating yeah down look good
to take it oh my mouth and then my
friend leave Martin know you're my best
friends at er I just wrote it all down
and then our then yeah and then and then
the ghost writer I'd John MacDonald yeah
he you know make it read probably you
know one little story are phoning us and
for money your friends it was a bit one
of the BMX Lance was that after the
crash you are a phone call from David
Beckham oh yeah what was that like was
that surprise of yeah I was in their
chair Ma's doing rehabilitation and I
there's some commotion and the like are
somebody's on the front for you nice
tour was one of my mates I might know I
used my rehabilitation time which
questions to me so I'll get it later you
know I'm walking up that's it
and then they come back again and and I
you know [__] them off again and then Oh
and then I realized that you know and
somebody was it was important and I had
to take the call when I got the room all
right
I friendly trying to Marie she passed me
the phone
I put it to my ear I was like Hello and
I was like ah hi Steven it's David
Beckham I'm like [__] off
say Isis they were just didn't you know
isn't just belief yeah I know and he was
so cool man
like you know we tried for good 20
minutes off now I know someone that
famous that you know I mean he's
Superliga phenomena to take time to
notice you know the world what's going
on in and I and then - yeah to spend
time talking to me and you know finding
things for me and you know it's it's
pretty amazing
he's special dude for sure yeah what are
you hoping to achieve with this book
what is the the goal
well the number one goal for that is
that I want people to be able to extract
from that or positively and and the
power of what it can do and then if also
you know there are millions of people
out there are paralyzed also they can
learn from this and gain from nation
mold myself into being a better person
and and to remember that you know if you
think you got nothing left it would
reach inside and dig deeper and there's
always something you can find yeah there
are [__] inspiration ah-ha-ha
appreciate you from a dawn of yeah
although I get his dremel quit now I got
a touch on something yeah definite
and all the time in the world yeah yeah
yeah no worries
take your time appreciate you bringing
the stone you know what yeah of course
yeah yeah yeah that's such a [__]
claw shot there's some good pictures
yeah yeah that one was the one you got
you Pedro Burnett crash yeah they want
yeah it's [__] pretty no yeah you can
see all the dirt on my back might crash
the double flip before it yeah yeah and
there's a lot of people just watching in
the background yeah I've never actually
seen the I've never watched a video of
the actual crush the videos it always
sort of a cop said oh yeah I got Paul to
be honest it's not something I really
need to see anyway yeah it's I mean I uh
I had to I had to see that I had to see
the crash because I want to know why arm
like this yeah I want to say if I was
you for sure because I want to know
exactly what happened you know people
all like people why why do you want to
see the crash from I don't see what I
did wrong and what went wrong you know
mm-hmm but when we do the the preview
would you would you rather us not show
it or kind of short part of it no no no
I don't mind
yeah yes just rather ask your major son
Lordsburg yeah cool is there anything
else you want to talk about yeah it
won't touch on my fiance will court yeah
it's called quite special all right so
when I was about 22 I went to I went to
Florida with my best friend I know and
my goal I'd call Erika all right you
know we just instantly was like you know
I love this girl so then I flew it back
out to California
and I and now I like to score so much
but I knew that I always were in my
prime upon my on my bike and I wasn't it
wasn't the right timing at all you know
I may be about five six years after my
accident because what we haven't said I
don't date is that you devote you got
divorced from the mother of your
children
yeah yeah yeah but fives have sheared
after my accident or I she got in
contact with me and I and then she came
out and I were the two kids chanting
Brooklyn and I and she didn't see me any
different mm-hmm and and that's like
that's so huge to me because you don't
see all that she'll care about no war
material stuff you know and I and then
dude I said I've fallen over and you
know I knew and it was it was difficult
to see she lived in Florida she has two
children and I live in California
and now another time I die I've got oh
you know I got really bad pneumonia yeah
and now I and it was really sketching my
carer left - I know I I knew I was
looking after my two kids
I've had them full custody for its
security other primary care oh yeah and
I yeah so I knew then I needed I needed
to help you know I try to do this all by
myself with the help of others but I I
need the family at this point you know
you know you know my dad is he came
across
God so many times in my to help me out
yeah and then I you know just decided
that I was torn between going to Florida
and don't like tangling just didn't you
know you want to be able to passing any
love but at the same time I got a deal
with my current situation and your your
sons are the most important thing yeah
yeah exactly
alright so so yeah we took so we spent a
year apart and then I
God it was only like here we start
talking maybe like four months ago and
then she came over she came over a month
ago for a couple weeks
yeah and then I would back on again yeah
it's amazing so you tell me the girls
yeah not yet not yet I'm gonna redo that
one good luck well I'm really happy for
you man yeah thanks I'm sure everyone
who's watching this as well cuz one
thing that is perfectly at me as you're
a really good human being you're a good
book hahaha
thanks we obviously know what this gun's
fantastically well yeah yes look on that
I'll prop I'll put the link in the
description below so anyone who wants to
buy you can just click straight on it
from this video fantastic and one
question I like the end it with yeah how
would you like to be remembered me I I'd
like to remember that someone that can
make the impossible possible and I'm
still yet to do that but yeah that's
gonna happen that's the look me I'm sure
if anyone can do it it's probably you
haha thanks
if you've enjoyed this video don't
forget hit the like button subscribe all
the links to stephen social media will
be there unhook thanks for watching and
we'll say as they're huge